hello and good evening welcome to
Intelligence Squared plus with me Dr
Ganesh Taylor and this evening I am
delighted to introduce Our Guest Dr
Philip gold
Philip is one of the world's leading
researchers of depressive illness since
1974 he has worked at the National
Institute of Health where he has served
as Chief neuroendocrine research and
Senior investigator in the National
Institute of Mental Health intramural
research program and the chief of the
section on neuroendocrinology
his new book which we'll be discussing
the themes of today is breaking through
depression I have a rather well thumbed
copy here as you can see that I've been
reading through and I'm I just wanted to
jump straight on in basically and say
Philip what a delight and pleasure it is
to have an opportunity to talk to you
this evening
um I I thoroughly enjoyed reading the
book though I'm loath to using the word
enjoy frankly to to to discuss uh or in
relation to depression but I thought
um
in the interest of getting our our
readers and and listeners this evening
uh all on the same page it might be
really helpful for us if you could
um give us your definition of what
depression is and clarify the two
different types of depression which you
talk about in the book that's something
that I certainly wasn't aware of and I
think that our listeners would really
really find that interesting so what is
depression and what what are the
differences between the two different
types of depression
depression is a disorder that occurs
because of a combination of
environmental factors stressors trauma
and genetic factors and you can become
depressed if you have a very strong
loading for genetics and uh benign
environmental course or if you have a
a rather stormy environmental course but
few if any genetic predisposing factors
it's like coronary artery disease
coronary arteries has genetic factors
but it occurs in a predisposing
environment if you overeat you don't
exercise if you're stressed
these will this is the predisposing
environment for depression the
predisposing environment is early loss
unavailable or excessively demanding
parents and stressors throughout the
life cycle
especially many and some severe
now uh I I will actually Define
depression by telling you about
melancholic and atypical depression
melancholic depression is associated
with a depressed mood
feeling uh and and the uh the
manifestations of the depressed mood
include in this form of depression which
blogs the term depression which suggests
a suppression of thought and feeling
it's an activation and there is anxiety
and the Cardinal manifestation of this
form of depression is uh
upsetness for self feelings of
worthlessness feelings of not being good
enough and fear that this sufficient
self has no prospects for future
gratification uh because of uh all the
liabilities
and
uh so the anxiety is attached primarily
to the cell
depression and melancholic depression is
associated with the loss of the capacity
to experience pleasure that's a very
major factor and in the country we call
that anhedonia the university to have
hedonic experiences
It's associated with physiological
changes
with activation of stress hormone
secretion
loss of sleep especially early morning
Awakening and loss of appetite
with the weight loss actually occurring
in many patients with melancholic
depression
from melancholic depression the symptoms
are worse in the morning when the stress
system is activated and they tend to
soften slightly in the evening when the
stress system is inactivated and as I'll
tell you later I think the
pathophysiology of melancholic
depression is that of a stress system
that has become activated and distorted
and stays in the on position so I'd love
to I'd love to get into that actually at
this point I know that you were about to
tell us about the other kind but
um I think it's really important to
address the fact that um you know the
you are one of um or one of the the
people who are spearheaded the the
understanding of depression as being
um a sort of stress response that has
gotten out of control if I understood
the book correctly at least
um and you you know you you told us a
bit about melancholic depression and how
um the physiology of it and how it
manifests differently over the course of
even a day which is something that I
didn't know at all
um and so I wondered if you could
um talk to that a little bit and say
well you know where did where did this
idea come from that depression is
actually a sort of physiological it is
physiological and it's root well you
know I wrote a two-part paper in the New
England Journal of Medicine about
depression represented the dysregulation
of the stress response and I Came Upon
This idea when I looked at the clinical
and biochemical manifestations of
depression and see especially
Melancholia and see how much it mirrored
the stress response
response is associated with anxiety but
it's not excessive anxiety that
interferes with developing a plan to
deal with the stressor
in melancholic oppression the anxiety is
enormous and overwhelming and as I
mentioned it's attached to the self
their feelings of worthlessness and a
sense that one is going to be
disconnected from others because of
their deficiencies and will be unable to
to work or to love
that's the anxiety of melancholic
depression the other manifestation of
stress is a slight detriment to
experience a pleasure uh you don't want
to be distracted by a beautiful scene uh
by by eating by the Temptation to sleep
by sex or by any other distraction so
the capacity to be uh attracted to these
uh uh stimuli is reduced in depression
but only in in stress but only to a
moderate degree
and it does not interfere with the
capacity to deal with the stressor
in major depression and melancholic
depression the capacity to experience
pleasure is virtually abolished
this is that you mentioned
and that's a that's a terrible feature
of depression that you can enjoy the
things that
enjoyed in the past you can't enjoy your
family you can't enjoy your friends you
can't enjoy feelings about yourself
which are so negative can't feel proud
of past accomplishments they seem
trivial and and irrelevant
so that's a second
correspondence between the stress
response but showing how much more
severely affected this parameter is
during melancholic depression
fascinating tell us about the other type
of depression the other type of
depression is a typical depression and
it seems like and so by the way this
form of depression cause depression
seems like an activation of the stress
response as I mentioned but it's being
distorted and markedly accentuated a
typical depression seems like the
antithesis of melancholic depression it
is not associated with anxiety but
rather a sense of uh not being connected
to self into the outside world to one's
memories uh melancholics are bombarded
by negatively charged emotional memories
of loss and failure and patients with
atypical depression are not
um they sleep too much they eat too much
they have fatigue and in contrast to
melancholic depression the symptoms are
worse in the evening when the stress
response is down because atypical
depression represents in an activation
of the stress response a state of uh
distance from one's upsetness and
anxiety
and many external stimuli now a typical
depression patients often feel lonely
because they feel out of touch not only
with themselves and their memories but
with others even their children and
their husbands
uh or wife so that these are the
features of atypical depression they
they differ they typical depression
occurs more earlier in the Life Course
and uh it is not necessarily exacerbated
during its course by stressors
whereas Melancholia occurs later on
the peak incidences during mid to late
adolescence but it can occur any time
during the life cycle
so that is quite different from atypical
depression as well one other thing about
atypical depression there is some
suggestion that patients with atypical
depression have a greater incidence of
early life trauma like sexual abuse or
other forms of abuse compared to
non-depressed patients but this is not
true of Melancholia
I mean they're so fascinating
um I I'm a biologist
um so I I love I love the study of this
kind of thing but
um as a human being of course I've also
rubbed shoulders with
um with this terrible condition at times
and I found it really interesting
actually that
um to you it it's it it and your field
is it's so apparent that there are these
two very different types of depression
whereas most of us just talk about
depression as if it's the same thing and
if there's something that I really
picked up throughout the course of your
book it's that they are very different
manifestations they they present very
differently and of course and you know a
big part of your book is about this the
way that they should be therefore
managed has to be quite different yes
the medications that atypical depressed
patients respond to are different than
some of those that melancholic patients
respond to in vice versa so the the
differentiation may make a difference in
the choice of antidepressants and in the
Psychotherapy and the recognition that
the melancholics in atypicals are
struggling massively but in different
ways
wow I mean if I can put you a bit on the
spot I think that they estimate that
about one in five people will suffer at
some point in the course of their lives
of depression what is the what is the
relative distribution of of you know how
many people will
I'm basically asking is melancholic
Depression more common in that case than
the atypical they're probably similarly
uh
uh common
um each
um
is equally represented in the in the
population so that uh 10 or 15 percent
of patients of individuals will have a
melancholic suppression and 10 or 15
percent
of uh individuals who have an atypical
depression yeah that's fascinating and
of course shift uh melancholics don't
tend to shift into being atypical and
atypicals don't tend to shift into being
melancholics
gosh that's really fascinating as well
um and of course you already mentioned
the fact that the atypical depression
tends to happen in people who uh are
somewhat younger and have typically been
through trauma which is something that
you talk about in the book as well about
how
um the sort of life stories of of
different people and can really
influence what type of depression they
end up with and therefore the kind of
treatment that they need of course
by the way I'll tell you wrote a paper
about uh
young very young children infants in
orphanages and he found that uh uh well
in the first month or two or three they
cried when they were not attended to or
when they were or when something went
wrong or frightened them but as time
progressed they stopped
responding to other people they stopped
crying when they were hungry or upset
and they turned down their emotional
systems perhaps to protect them from
overwhelming uh distress and that may be
a severe form of atypical depression and
that atypical depression may represent
an effort to Tamp down
uh feelings uh rather than to be in
Greater touch with them
[Music]
um
throughout the course of the book you
tell extremely powerful
um stories both of your own life and of
the lives of other uh colleagues and
people who write
um who've written these books and and
um I wonder if I may which of the
stories that you recount in the book did
you find the most challenging to to
share with with your readers or to
recount
I think the one about my own depression
when I was around 20 which was the only
one I had was the most difficult to
render and it worked quite a while uh to
get it into uh uh into its final form
and
um it taught me a lot about depression I
don't underestimate
the profound impact it has on people how
painful it is
and how uh much of a relief it is to
have it pass
and uh
I came ultimately to believe that
because the stress system is so
intimately involved in stress authors
the uh the structure and the function of
the stress system and brain and causes
loss of tissue and neurodegeneration
that uh
uh
they're a very serious physical physical
consequences of depression but they can
be treated effectively
uh I was genuinely struck by that in in
the book as well about I think this the
number you said was somewhere in the
order of seven to ten years will get
knocked off the the sort of life
expectancy of somebody who undergoes
major depression that's right and that's
independent of suicide that's because
the physiological components of these
depressions which I'll now mention uh
which can go on for months or even years
uh uh affect
multiple hormonal systems sympathetic
nervous system and depressed patients uh
surprisingly are very inflamed they have
much inflammation in the brain and much
inflammation in the body and that's
because stress precipitates inflammation
in the brain in the body and I think the
reason that's so is that in very early
uh thousands of years ago
when individuals
uh perceived the danger of stress they
had a full-blown stress response
to premonetorily protect them if they
got into a fight or flight or our mortal
struggle uh with another being and I
think for that reason uh stress
precipitates uh the stress response even
now so that if uh emotional stress like
public speaking public speaking causes
an activation of the stress response and
a change in in many of these
physiological parameters that I
mentioned inflammation increase in
stress hormones
and a variety of other changes that
adversely affect honey so that because
of these changes depression is also a
systemic disorder
so that patients have premature
coronary artery disease stroke diabetes
and osteoporosis and that shortens their
lives by Seven Years
and so it's a major medical emergency
actually to have depression and I think
that's poorly understood that it's
associated with severe and long-lasting
physiological changes that shorten the
lifespan and that the depression needs
to be treated and that before the
depression is treated perhaps uh
prophylactic medications can be given to
decrease the propensity to coronary
heart disease stroke diabetes or
osteoporosis that's a really interesting
point and of course I mean I think part
of the reason why this book is so timely
is um thankfully there's starting to be
a bit more of
um sort of public awareness around the
around depression and mental health in
general so you know your book comes out
of one you know at a good time basically
to help
um Stoke on those conversations I was
struck by
um how what you just said so eloquently
about how
um
effectively depression has these
incredibly sort of physiological effects
and how that was then that basically
translated historically into this
realization that perhaps if we address
those physiological systems we might be
able to feed back into the the sort of
the the resolution of the depression
right so that's the idea of
antidepressants
correctly so and because of this given
the tremendous suffering psychologically
the changes in cognitive function the
difficulty thinking clearly and because
these premature systemic diseases the
World Health Organization ranks
depression as a second grade of greatest
cause of disability worldwide and the
greatest cause of disability in
individuals under 40.
yeah I mean I can believe that I mean
especially after reading this book I
really have to say I think it it really
opened my eyes to to the severity of the
circumstance
but um it also leads me to to asking you
so obviously a substantial amount of
what you wrote about is is
um to make some assumptions about your
readership and and maybe you share too
much about myself but if you pick up a
book about depression inevitably of
course some of us are slightly
interested in the intellectual pursuit
of understanding what it is and
um but I suspect most of us want to know
how to help right either help ourselves
or help those around us who
um might be undergoing
um depression and you talk a lot about
the different kinds of treatments and
therapies and the sort of the the
history of how they developed and of
course you yourself have been heavily
involved in that could you could you
give me a as or us who are listening to
this
a real sense of what happened in that in
that case where you told us the first
time you used ssris on a patient and
over the course of a few weeks or their
condition improve I mean what what was
that like to see I was astonished and
related to see it I've actually trained
in a psychoanalytically oriented uh
psychiatric training program and never
use medications until I got to the NIH
so this was the first time I saw a
patient snap out of a depression almost
in a moment uh after three weeks on an
antidepressant and I thought it was
extraordinary
and I regretted the fact that we didn't
use medication during my residency
yeah yeah I mean I I could only imagine
I mean especially after hearing about
how Depression had previously been
treated and how you know the history of
of these very difficult circumstances
that patients would find themselves
under
um it it yeah it really struck me
reading it but also you know having hope
in these circumstances is really
critical right so you I have to say I
was struck by the fact that by the end
of the book I was thinking well okay so
um I've learned that depression comes in
two different forms this sort of
melancholic kind and this atypical kind
and that the way they manifest in terms
of literal times of day is very
different but it seems that in in
explaining all these differences you
also present
um all the different possible handles
that we could use to try and improve a
patient's condition so for example
um you know you talk about how sleep
cycles can really really improve or
refining a patient's sleep cycles can
really improve their their outcome right
that's correct the especially
Melancholia who lose sleep if you help
treat their sleeplessness that begins to
ameliorate the intensity of the
depression yeah and that's amazing isn't
it yes and if you and if patients have
bipolar disorder and they're depressed
if you sleep deprive them they switch
into mania so they need to get good
sleep as well or they will be beset by
uh manic symptoms
I mean you say it so so calmly and
coolly to me I was I was genuinely like
a mixture of intellectually awed but
also genuinely filled with a sense of
hope I mean don't get me wrong I I
understand that sleep is not easy to
come by but what a wonderful set of of
possible therapies you place in front of
us there was sleep there was the effect
of hormones there was different kinds of
um chemicals as well right you talked a
lot about lithium I believe there was a
chapter on that yes
um
yes please one thing in addition to the
medications which we'll talk about
because it's the stress system that is
affected and because stress affects the
structure
and the function of the stress system
uh
patients with depression actually have
death of cells in components of the
stress system that encode
the depressive syndrome but in addition
the burden of early environmental
stresses or stresses throughout so that
it is very important
to along with pharmacological treatment
and depression that patients perceive
psychotherapy because if they have
behavioral traits or conflicts or ideas
that predispose of depression and
they're not addressed they may override
the uh efficacy of antidepressants and I
gave a case history of someone who
responded to psychotherapy it's very
clear in this case history if this
person had not responded the level of
his conflicts and the distress they
caused him would have on his positive
response to medications
so
um
yes I'm really glad you raised that of
course therapy is something that
um
as I personally always thought it was
really critical and it was wonderful to
see you actually front load that in your
in your Armory of things that we can do
to help patients with depression because
of course we say it as if you know it's
easy to come by but actually securing
therapy is at least in the UK extremely
challenging to get hold of therapists so
could you tell us a little bit more
about you know just in in terms of the
relative balance of of therapy versus a
sort of chemical or physiological
intervention
um what are the relative importances
they're both important I found that
actually when patients are giving
antidepressants and they respond they
participate much more actively and
freely in Psychotherapy I think that
there may be patients who will not
respond to psychotherapy alone because
the biology is so powerful that's really
interesting I would start
both but I would start with
psychopharmacology
and then try to get a response and
continue afterwards rather than stopping
the Psychotherapy
to put together the picture of why
someone might be vulnerable
um logically to depression hmm that's
really interesting while talking about
that
um there has been a lot of discussion
these days or a rise in popularity at
least in in this idea of
well both in terms of biohacking so in
terms of using Technologies and and
chemicals to sort of optimize our bodies
and and cure these things uh sort of
ailments that we have but within that of
course psychedelics are undergoing quite
the Renaissance and
um the big The Big Field at which
they're supposedly you know being hailed
as being so critical is
um depression and drug drug resistant
depression in particular and and you
have a chapter on the matter so could
you could you tell us uh tell us how you
felt the first time you heard about
these psychedelics and their potential
use in the clinic
I was intrigued but uh initially
skeptical but when the data came out
uh and it showed that uh the
psychedelics had effects on biological
components of the depression uh that
resolved even before the depression
resolved I became convinced and the data
are now really uh overwhelming New
England journalism is published positive
uh reports about psychedelics treating
depression better than conventional
antidepressants uh I think they're
remarkable and I think they will become
very very important in the treatment
depression they do two things
differently ordinary antidepressants
take three to four weeks to work
psychedelics can work after a day
even if uh and and will sustain an
antidepressant response to 10 or 12 days
even if no more medication is given
and that over time if they're given at a
certain interval they can sustain
remissions from depression
the one that has been tested the most is
psilocybin and it's just extraordinary
in its capacity to reach oppression it
has other positive effects in addition
to what you said about uh drug
dependency patients with anorexia
nervosa respond positively two
psychedelics and I studied anorexia
nervosa for many years and such patients
were really very difficult to treat and
didn't respond to ordinary had a
presence so I think these are a powerful
modality and I think the individuals who
initiated these studies and conducted
them earn a lot of our gratitude
indeed I mean so
to sort of
well to wrap that up then in that case
how how do you see the the treatment of
depression unfolding going forward we
have all these new tools new treatment
options new therapies and both physical
and also sort of spoken therapies
um how would you in the ideal world
going forward what would you like to
imagine would happen to somebody if they
if they did develop depression
before I do that let me talk about the
biological changes in the brain that
occur in melancholic depression first
and know much more about melancholic
depression than we do about atypical
depression so I'll focus on that
um depression and melancholics is a
neurodegenerative disease
tissues and cells are lost
there are
just like in Parkinson's disease you
lose dopamine neurons you lose
neurons in several areas of the stress
system that influence uh this the
natural history and that are involved in
the response to treatments
you lose tissue in one area that I call
the controller of the stress system that
is involved in modulating self-esteem
which is very much affected in
depression
it controls to a certain extent the
levels of anxiety
it modulates the capacity to experience
pleasure
and it uh increases
the or rather decreases some of the
physiological changes that occur that
are damaging in depression such as the
hormonal changes and the changes in
sympathetic nervous system activity so
that these specific areas become
potential targets
for uh new classes of antidepressants
so that uh we know that a couple of
other aspects of the biology one of the
things that happens in Melancholia is
that there is a loss of a compound
called brain derived neurotrophic Factor
and it's called bdnf bdnf is necessary
to nourish and protect
neurons from damage and from uh stimuli
that can cause their death and it
protects neurons and what stress does is
it depletes bdnf
and so that patients with major
depression have
decreased levels of bbnf and that
contributes to many of the clinical and
biochemical manifestations of depression
all right
most antidepressants even the older ones
after three or four weeks actually
increase bdnf secretion but slightly so
they're not as powerful as some of the
newer antidepressants that I'll talk
about later that I have profound and
intense effects on bdnf secretion
interactions and that produce remissions
within hours or days
so that targeting the bdnf system itself
ideally uh would be a great way to go
about treating depression we don't have
a compound yet that can actually
specifically increase bdnf but we're
testing compounds for their capacity uh
that specifically activate the bnnf
system directly but we do have compounds
that activate it indirectly that are
being tested and that are being utilized
and so compounds that activate bdnf uh
will uh
be effective in treating uh melanchol
depression and
there is research going on all over the
world looking for compounds to do that
better
stress stress also uh
impacts the stress system in other ways
it decreases the capacity of the
pleasure and Reward Center to experience
pleasure
and compounds that increase the capacity
to experience pleasure also have
antidepressant features and so people
are also screening compounds that
activate the pleasure in the world
center
and when that Center is activated the
bdnf system is somewhat down regulated
as well
so that's another major Target
for the treatment of major depression
there are two processes that promote the
capacity to respond to stress and that
are
impacted and diminished in depression
one is called neuroplasticity or the
connection among nerve cells and that is
diminished in depression and the other
is called neurogenesis which is the
birth of new neurons
which help deal with
the rapidly changing
landscape of what is happening during
the severe stressor and compounds that
incomplete that increase the connections
among neurons or that increase
neurogenesis are also effective in
treating depression and so
folks are screening uh
antidepressant compounds that increase
the connections among neurons and
neuroplasticity
and so they are other targets new
targets for the treatment of depression
that did not exist before these recent
data emerged and and so uh and the
psychedelics uh ketamine for instance is
one of the psychedelics that treats
depression rapidly but it causes some
people a transient but problematic uh
side effect and that is a dissociative
reaction where depressed patients come
out of uh lose contact with themselves
their identity and uh their settings and
where they are and that is very
distressing and needs a psychiatrist
present there when that happens and so
the use of ketamine has to occur in the
context of doses being given in the
presence of a psychiatrist for two to
three or four hours
and um
that's a problem and people are
developing new uh psychedelic compounds
that don't cause dissociation uh that
will be
more flexible in the treatment of major
depression
also looking at compounds the all
psychedelic compounds activate something
called the serotonin-2 receptor
if you give psilocybin or ketamine and
you block the serotonin 2 receptor you
don't get the uh psychedelic impact
of these uh agents and and folks are now
looking at developing uh serotonin two
stimulators that don't precipitate
the Psychedelic
experiences so that might be simpler
although some of us and I myself believe
that the Psychedelic experience itself
which puts people in touch with the
capacity to feel connected to all of
mankind to uh to be more connected to
the people that they love to get more
out of psychotherapy
and to uh to to feel more and to see
more in the environment that these may
also be uh
helpful in the treatment of depression
so that the Psychedelic compounds that
produce these effects May ultimately be
more effective than serotonin 2 receptor
stimulators uh that uh rather
serotonin two stimulators that don't
produce the Psychedelic effect
that's fascinating I mean you you did
address my question beautifully there
Philip you basically said yes we have
all these new approaches and
Technologies and they're wonderful but
our work isn't done yet
um so I guess uh that's a that's a good
note for us to to sort of start wrapping
up the formal part of our conversation
and the last thing I wanted to say was
um
what what would you what would your
parting shot to one of your readers
who's listening to this conversation be
what is your hope for for those of us
who've read your book
one thing especially for people who have
depression or who know people who are
depressed or who have family members
were depressed depression is
fundamentally a biological disorder that
is also uh
uh promoted by adverse experiences but
the depression is not an illness that
occurs to people because they're weak or
inadequate or unable to deal with the
demands and stresses of life
and that uh as a matter of fact I feel
the people who bear the enormous
distress of depression are very strong
that they can bear terrible distress
about themselves uh inability to
experience pleasure loss of Hope in the
future and still keep going
hoping that the depressions will resolve
and so I have a lot of respect for
people who bear depression and I think
people who had depression and who
respond emerged stronger they develop uh
means of coping with the depression
while the depressed that persist after
they recover that may help them cope
with the ordinary stresses and strains
of life
what a wonderfully inspiring and Humane
point to end on thank you so much for
talking to me Philip
um our audience have been sending in
questions while we've been talking and
so for the last uh sort of five to ten
minutes I am I am going to
um ask you some of their questions or
pass them on to you and you can address
them right with no further Ado I will
turn to the first question so
um Sarah asks do you think that CBT so
cognitive behavioral therapy is
effective on its own or do you think it
needs to be paired with medication
I think that for mild depressions it
might be effective on its own but in
almost all cases it needs to be paired
with medications with medications
uh and I think people respond better to
CBT as well as the Insight or in
Psychotherapy when they respond to the
antidepressant hmm
um
yes I think you mentioned something
about that in our conversation as well
um we have another question specifically
now asking
um so of course I note that you're based
in in the US and and this question
clearly is coming from the United
Kingdom and we call them GPS the the
average doctor that you'll go to talk to
to get triage before you engage with the
full medical system I'm not sure what
you call them General Practitioners
excellent right so the question asks do
you think uh General Practitioners
actually understand illnesses like
depression or anorexia
some do and some don't I think the many
who do I think understand it very well
and can probably undertake treatment
initially before referring to a
psychiatrist although in many cases uh
referring to someone who's an expert
psychopharmacologists and
psychotherapists might be necessary to
treat many depressions
but I think many others who really don't
pay much attention to depressions I
don't understand much about it don't see
it as a biological disturbance don't
think automatically of perhaps
considering antidepressants in someone
who is uh significantly depressed and
that's a problem
that's very interesting
um from Maria in Bedford she's asking
um is there any data on how social media
or increased use of technological
devices are impacting our stress levels
and presumably therefore by extension
depression
there are preliminary studies and
anecdotal data that they do
that they they cause a lot of distress
for many people especially adolescents
for instance who might see on social
media people who preferentially report
on things they're doing that are
exciting and gratifying and they wonder
why they're not having such experiences
and they feel bad about themselves
I think that's one potential mechanisms
for adolescents I think more work needs
to be done but I think that it does
increase the stress as well as provide
enormous information and and education
to people as well
yeah
that's interesting I'm seeing an
interesting question
um here
um
looking at the role of the diet
basically potentially on on on
depression the specific question is
um have you or feel free to to indicate
if any of your colleagues or anyone else
that you know of has actually looked at
the effects of
um fasting and and any evidence that
that might impact specifically
increasing bdnf
um levels of course there's a lot of
interest at the moment in this
intermittent fasting and prolonged
fasting and aging and sort of the
reduction of inflammation so have you
ever looked at that Philip no I haven't
in but I think it's a very important
question and I think that uh that um
fasting in other ways of reducing
inflammation
and eating foods that have less of an
impact on information like high fat diet
uh potentially might one day be shown to
have an impact on the susceptibility to
depression and its response to treatment
it's a good question
so let's let's sort of end on on the the
this question which I'm going to use to
sort of paraphrase a number of questions
I'm seeing here I guess one of the big
questions that people have
um about depression both for themselves
but also for for their loved ones
is
even
is it ever possible to be completely
cured of depression is is is depression
something that can be cured or is
depression something that is managed
managed well or managed poorly
yes what are your thoughts on that so
far a lifelong recurring disorder
and I'm not sure I think some people go
into remission and stay in remission for
long periods of time or indefinitely but
I don't think they're necessarily cured
I think one of the mistakes that people
make in giving antidepressants is to
give them only until the patient
responds
or to keep it on board for three or four
more months and I keep patients on
antidepressants for a long time if not
even indefinitely
to prevent uh theory on Saturday
question the data uh come from
short-term studies if you stop
antidepressants after a year the uh the
susceptibility to another depression is
around 30 to 40 percent but if you keep
it on board it's less than 10 percent
goodness that's really eye-opening I
mean um
humor me uh Philip I has anyone done any
you mentioned uh of course that you can
see the physiological damage the
neurodegeneration that that depression
has upon the brain and using scanning
Technologies has anyone ever looked to
see in patients that have undergone a
remission I'm assuming that that damage
remains but or does it actually heal
partially if not completely reversible
oh wow wow so that they go and you would
think the depression the susceptibility
of depression goes away but I think
probably some Stigmata might remain uh
at the prolonged remission as a presence
do help or plead some of the Lost issue
not entirely but ameliorated very
significantly good question do you think
that genetics is a part of that
yes I think
I think cysts
presence
then perhaps the anatomic changes may
continue or progress and depressions may
be uh recurrent
fascinating okay I think we have time
for for one more question and this one
actually pertains to obsessive
compulsive disorder which
um
I'm not sure that you mentioned
explicitly in in the book but
um the question is is it also a
biological disturbance regarding sort of
stress levels and anxiety as it is with
depression so broadly speaking might
they be related
they're related they have some
overlapping uh biochemical features
obsessive impulsive disorder is clearly
biological there's no question about it
people have identified areas in the
brain that are affected in processes
that are effective in terms of
information processing letting thoughts
go flexibility of uh of of thinking and
feeling
and there is a full neurobiology that is
impacting on that and there are some
very effective
treatments for obsessive-compulsive
disorder ssris are effective
and
there is one that people don't use very
much
it's a little tricky but it really works
in many people who have resistant
obsessive compulsive disorder called
clomipramine
which a very good treatment for
obsessive compulsive disorder but people
who haven't have a biological disorder
need to be treated and need medication
fascinating stuff
I mean
um I could keep talking to you for hours
Philip and and I'm sure people listening
would would be in for the ride on that
front but I'm I'm gonna have to thank
you
um for this fascinating conversation the
book is again just for those of you who
haven't bought it yet necessarily is uh
breaking through depression it is
available
um from any of your local bookstores
um uh I've been Ganesh Taylor and you've
been watching or listening to
Intelligence Squared thank you so much
for your time Dr Philip gold pleasure
thank you for wonderful questions thank
you